joining us now Florida Senator Marco
Rubio you know senator I look at for
example I know there are a lot of Cuban
Americans I've gotten to know many of
them they I will tell you it is an
amazing stories I have a very good
friend of mine that passed away his land
his family land was stolen his
neighbor's land was stolen when Castro
came to power many of his friends and
neighbors were murdered by Castro and
his thugs he barely made it out alive
hundreds of thousands of people getting
broken down the lappa dated rickety
boats shark-infested waters or get in an
inner tube with a paddle to get away
from Cuba and this guy's telling us how
great Castro is and how great the USSR
was well because I think he's gotten
away with four years saying that he's a
socialist he's actually not a social
he's a Marxist this is Marxism and
Marxism is based on the belief that no
person has any value as an individual
that your value is that you're a member
of a class second Marxism is based on
the belief that an employer and an
employee a worker and an owner can't
both help each other and both be better
off the worker gets good pay the
employee employer makes a profit on the
capital they've invested but his ideas
are Marxist ideas and Marxism always
leads to authoritarianism and and
dictatorship eventually it does
everywhere in the world that's been
tried and as you point out in my home
state of Florida we have hundreds of
thousands of people who have come to
this country fleeing some of the very
same policies that we're now seeing
advocated on a debate stage in one of
our two major political parties Bernie
Sanders is the likely Democratic nominee
and frankly and he's a Marxist and these
are Marxist ideas and they need to be
called for what they are okay with 252
days outside of what I think is a
defining moment in American politics
I've never seen a more radical group of
people than these Democrats and these
ideas and pretty much nationalizing
everything or you could take the
Bloomberg health care plan which is if
you're 95 go home see your family we're
not gonna pay for your health care go
home and die he actually is on tape
saying that here's my question so you
got this radical group of Democrats
something is happening where President
Trump especially in the last 1012 polls
African Americans Hispanic Americans
there is a transformation doubling
tripling quadrupling
even the amount of support that he got
in 2016
do you see that happening and what does
it mean if it's real well and I think
part of it frankly is just how off the
rails the Democratic Party has become
look at they they all will say and
Bernie Sanders in particular they'll say
well we still believe in private
industry and they like to compare
themselves to Nordic countries
number-one Nordic countries are actually
not socialist you know I used to
actually buy into that and you look at
it carefully it's not true they have
free enterprise you know the average
corporate tax rate in Nordic country is
around twenty one percent they don't
even have a minimum wage in Sweden they
have Universal a school choice for
everybody so they have a big welfare
state but they do it and they have high
taxes but they are not socialist
countries not what they're talking about
is nationalizing health care that's 20
percent over twenty percent of our
economy nationalizing energy through the
green new deal that's another
significant percentage they talk about
the SCC controlling the internet which
people think about how much of our
economy is run through there
you've now nationalized sixty seventy
percent of your economy and who knows
what other sectors they want to go after
you the US as we know it which has
created a standard of living and
advanced the human condition more than
any single country under capitalism in
the entire world of the creation of man
would would be the we would literally
default under these plans but thank you
for being with us that are good to see
you